(man screaming)
- Oh!
No!
Move!
It is officially the 30th
anniversary of "Home Alone."
It's one of my favorite
movies of all time.
It's actually one of my
first movies that I watched
on VHS coming to the
United States in 1995.
Boy, did I just age myself?
I'm watching some of
the most painful clips
from the two movies.
I know some other channels
have done this years
and years ago.
Let's give a huge thank you to them
for coming up with the idea,
injury reaction time.
- I can't seem to find my toothbrush
so I'll pick one up when I go out today.
Other than that I'm in good shape.
Ah!
- If you have ever shaved
and then put aftershave on,
it does burn a bit
because there are micro tears of the skin
and when the alcohol seeps in there
it actually causes burning and stinging.
I actually had a horrendous
experience like this
when I went swimming in the Dead Sea.
If you don't know what the Dead Sea is
all you need is a
picture to see the blocks
of salt floating in it and
I actually shaved my face
before going and I actually think my body
because I wanted to get an even tan.
When I went into the Dead Sea
and I had those little
micro tears from shaving,
oh my God my body caught on fire.
So, I know what he feels like.
(light music)
(wood cracking)
Oh, oh!
- Whoa!
(shelf crashing)
- Oh!
This is such a typical pediatric injury.
Ankle sprains could be quite
common here, knee sprains,
and also because the
shelves actually fractured
and broke like that,
those wooden sharp edges
can give you a serious,
serious laceration.
- Got some nice presents for ya.
- Be a good little fellow
now and open the door.
(gun firing)
(Harry screeching)
- I'm assuming based on his reaction
it hit him in the testicular area
and it had to hurt.
There's a lot of nerve endings there
and it's also quite dangerous
because there's a lot of blood flow there.
So, if you rupture some
of those blood vessels
you actually get expansion and swelling.
It could actually lead
to a condition known
as testicular torsion where
the spermatic cord that leads
to the testicle actually kind of spins
on itself and cuts off the
circulation to the testicle
which leads to a lot more pain
and even the testicle dying
if it's not treated surgically in time.
(whimsical music)
(foot squeaking)
(Harry hollering)
(body thudding)
Oh!
(Harry squeaking)
The reason he's probably
doing the (squeaking)
is he had the wind knocked out of him.
Imagine landing so hard
that it actually expels all the air out
and you're not able to
normally take a breath in
because remember, in order
to take a deep breath in,
your body has to create negative pressure
in order to suck the air in.
And if you can't expand your ribs
'cause they just got hit
and there days you can't create
the negative pressure needed
to take a deep breath.
(chain rattling)
(iron scraping)
Oh no.
(cord whipping)
(iron thudding)
Oh!
That fell right on his face.
You could easily fracture your orbit
which is the bone surrounding your eye.
Like imagine if it hit
him dead on into the eye,
you could lose the eye completely.
But, what I don't understand
here is how it hit him
so perfectly on the forehead,
but then didn't break his nose.
(suspenseful music)
(skin singing)
(Harry screaming)
(Harry blowing)
(body thudding)
- Ow!
(Harry yelling)
(skin hissing)
- Immediately after getting a burn
you don't wanna necessarily go and put it
into something icy because
that can actually exacerbate the burn
and make it feel worse.
So, you wanna run your burn
under room temperature if anything.
The danger of receiving a burn,
especially on the hand, is when burns heal
they often form scar tissue
that form contractures
which actually lead the hand
to be in a flexed position.
And when it's in a
flexed position like this
it makes it very difficult
for it to be usable.
So, a lot of occupational therapy,
physical therapy, needs to be done
in order to return the hand to normal.
Also important to remember
that there's multiple types
of burns from heat, meaning thermal burns,
electric burns, chemical
burns, there's even ice burns.
Like if you hold dry ice onto your hand,
that's like minus 100 degrees
Fahrenheit or whatever it is,
you can burn your hand with the ice.
That's why when we
recommend icing your knee
or your shoulder or something,
we always say put it
over a piece of fabric
so it's not directly on your skin
'cause then you can actually
cause yourself frostbite.
Frostbite is essentially a burn.
(feet squishing)
Oh no!
(Marv yelling)
(body thudding)
Not only did he have a puncture wound
from a nail in his foot,
he fell from like the eighth step.
If you ever are to get
like a nail in your foot,
while it's important to get
it out after a period of time,
you don't wanna rush to do it yourself
in case that it's hitting an artery
and actually putting
pressure on that artery
and preventing you from bleeding out.
'Cause it's very possible,
okay, you pull it out
and now you just have a
ton of blood coming out.
And if you're not in a medical
setting to address that
that is a problem and make sure
your tetanus is up to date.
(blowtorch blazing)
(Harry yelling)
Oh!
No!
Move!
Oh, that's a full thickness
third degree burn.
The way that we do it
in the medical setting
to decide how severe someone's burns are,
outside of the first,
second, and third degree,
we also give a percentage of
the total body surface area
that has been burned.
And we use the rule of nines
and we decide what percentage is burned,
how we should adjust,
and we think about fluid replacement.
If a large percentage
of the body surface area has been burned,
that cripples a person's
ability to keep their fluids.
And they actually become dehydrated
and need fluids with
electrolytes repleted quickly.
Otherwise they can go
into hypovolemic shock.
Their kidneys can shut
down and they could die
as a result of this dehydration.
(whimsical music)
- Heads up!
- Huh?
(can thudding)
Ah!
(body thudding)
- A lot of people don't realize,
when you fall on your back,
you really don't support your head well
so your head ends up hitting afterwards.
Your brain actually suffers
trauma onto the side
that you got hit
as well as the other side of the brain.
It's actually called a
countercoup type of injury
where the brain slides to the back,
hits the back of the skull,
but then because you landed and you shake,
it actually hits the
front of the skull as well
so you have injury on
both sides of the brain.
- Don't move.
- Marv, what are you doing?
Marv.
(crowbar thudding)
Ah geez!
- Oh my God.
Not only can you fracture
ribs in the sternum,
if you hit like the point of
maximum impulse from the heart
and you hit it right at the wrong time,
in the middle of its beat,
you can actually stop
the heart from beating.
This is like a known phenomenon
in little league baseball.
If you hit a grounder
and it hits the child
in the chest right at that moment,
it could actually stop the heart.
And that's why there's
mandated defibrillators
that need to be present
at little league games
because of this.
(suspenseful music)
(woman gasps)
- Well, hello.
(fist thudding)
(Marv grunting)
- He did it.
- Did what?
(fist thudding)
(Harry grunting)
- She's a strong punch
for a one-punch knockout.
It's easy, easy to break
a facial bone here.
Easy, easy to get a concussion here.
I feel like this is what Logan Paul
versus Floyd Mayweather's gonna look like.
(horns blaring)
(electricity buzzing)
(Marv yelling)
When you get electrocuted
through an alternating current,
it's actually really difficult to let go
of whatever object is
causing electrocution
and you can start
developing muscle spasms,
cramps, shaking, arrhythmias
of your heart, seizures.
All these things start going
because your body has a
natural electrical gradient.
The way that your heart beats,
the way that your brain fires,
once that is interrupted
by this extraneous bit of electricity
it's incredibly painful
and damaging to your body.
- I'm coming Harry!
- Marv!
(Harry yelling)
- No.
(body thudding)
No.
We actually have criteria that we follow
of when we should be
cat scanning folks head
when they come in from a trauma
and part of that criteria
is knowing the mechanism of injury.
Falling 40 feet from
the air onto a metal car
and having it shatter like this
is the definition of needing a cat scan.
(brick whirling)
(brick thudding)
Brick from the fourth story,
whatever that is, to the head.
You're not getting up from that.
If it hits on an angle
especially, that's death.
First of all, good aim, but that's death.
(brick whirling)
(brick thudding)
(Harry yelling)
Oh my God.
The second concussion is
always worse than the first.
When you get your first concussion,
your brain gets shaken up.
There's inflammatory cells.
Your brain is very susceptible
to getting permanently injured.
So, right here, the fact
that he got one concussion
and then got hit with another brick,
he's getting six months of headaches,
six months of light sensitivity,
if not dying immediately,
like I don't know what's happening.
(brick whirling)
(Marv yelling)
(brick thudding)
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
(nail shooting)
(Marv yelling)
There's so much wrong with that.
He got shot in the groin with a nail.
That's gonna need a urologist.
Like that's gonna need urgent surgery.
You need to see if any
structures were damaged.
You need to put it back together.
In the face?
There's nerves in the face.
You can disrupt nerves.
You can lose sensation in the face.
(whimsical music)
(Harry laughing)
(hands squishing)
(harry yelling)
(body thudding)
Okay.
Like when you hear about people
who survive skydiving accidents or falls,
it's almost usually because
something broke their fall
or they fell onto a hill where it was
like an angle and their
momentum carried them
and they didn't just
come to a complete stop.
My man here came to a complete stop.
Why is that dangerous?
'Cause your body comes to a complete stop,
but the force doesn't.
So, the force goes right
through everything.
All of the organs smash
against themselves,
the bones break 'cause they're hitting.
Uh.
- Harry!
I've reached the top.
(Marv yelling)
(body thudding)
Okay, two bricks in
the face from the roof.
- Three, three.
- Three bricks from the roof.
Maybe he got lucky.
Two-story fall onto the face, death.
Like you're not surviving this.
Like there's no human
that's arriving this.
He's bleeding out internally.
Just everything in his body
should be broken at this point.
(bones cracking)
Yeah, no.
- Ah.
- No.
I know this is a movie,
but I'm trying to critique the
medical accuracy nonetheless.
Speaking of medical accuracy,
here's me pranking some of
my close doctor friends.
Or, if you need a good laugh,
here's me reviewing some
of the S and L commercials that they had.
Medical commercials,
medical advertisements,
'cause we do that here in the states.
As always stay happy and healthy.
(light music)